tenants at a crime-ridden apex property
on the east side of the valley are in
jeopardy about the future of their homes
last weekend there was a deadly shooting
there now the county is attempting to
take action against the unlicensed
property it's a story the i-team's
vanessa murphy first broke last august
and been has been following since
the apex apartments here are crime
ridden police are constantly here
tenants are paying rent for deplorable
conditions we reached out to
commissioner tick sagerbloom since he
represents this area he agreed to come
and talk to us all i can say is we're on
top of it now and it's not going to
they can't they can't dodge us anymore
clark county commissioner tick
sagerbloom says he was here two weeks
ago with the owners of the apex
apartments asking them to make repairs
and to hire two full-time security
guards he says a deadly shooting here
sunday and the condition of the place
now make it clear the owners aren't
cooperating the county comes out and
boards these things up
we bill them for that they always like i
think over three thousand dollars for
that on thursday clark county filed a
lawsuit against the owners and their
business california-based
pro-residential services the county
points out as the i-team first reported
the property is operating without a
license and alleges code violations
failure to pay taxes and more
so you've walked through here before yes
with with the owner
going through fix this fix this a major
issue squatters during our visit with
commissioner sakerbloom tuesday a woman
walked out of what was a boarded-up unit
county records reveal sunday marks the
fourth homicide here in about a year
that's in addition to nearly 700 calls
for service a stabbing 19 shootings a
swat search for a drug house and 50
burglaries or robberies
as far as i'm concerned i don't know
anybody that has a lease here that's
conducting that type of activity
this is all exterior problems that are
coming out of this property and causing
these problems for these families in an
email to the i-team on april 12 the
owners claimed they were trying to work
with the county it just seems to be
whatever they're trying to do is just
not working so
i would say no commissioner sager bloom
says if the county shuts down the
apartments here representatives will
work with the tenants to make sure they
find a new home
vanessa murphy live local now